we begin this hour with a story that
we've been closely following about a
gridlock in the ports that is driving up
prices and threatening holiday shopping
plans several major shippers are trying
to expand their working hours to tackle
the crisis and the port of los angeles
has announced it will operate around the
clock the port of los angeles and long
beach handle 40 of the nation's imports
carter evans is at the port of los
angeles carter good morning
good morning a union rep tells me dock
workers are ready to work around the
clock in fact it's already in their
current contract but all these extra
hours well that's going to cost a lot of
money and it's going to be expensive and
the union says change doesn't come
easily when it affects the carriers
bottom
line how long are the weights here to
pick up a load sometimes
like
seven to nine hours mana says gonzales
is one of thousands of truck drivers
feeling the impact of the port log jam
and he's concerned even a 24 7 schedule
won't speed things up enough
yeah sometimes we sleep on the
in gate so you're already sleeping here
sometimes
truckers at the port of l.a sometimes
have to line up for hours just to pick
up one container and then where do they
take them most warehouses are full and
that's delaying deliveries even further
the biden administration's deal to open
the ports of los angeles and long beach
around the clock is an attempt to tackle
the backlog of nearly 60 cargo ships
carrying a quarter million containers
usc professor nick vias is a global
supply chain expert other than telling
these ports to stay open 24 hours can
the president do anything to make this
work i don't think there is much he can
do if you just open up the port all
you're doing is pushing the bottleneck
further downstream so we need the
truckers the draige company the
warehouses the logistics folks in
between
tony yabika's bike shop is just down the
street from the ports when we met him a
month ago he was waiting for bikes he
ordered last year do you think it's
going to help you get bikes faster no
probably not
i i don't think it's going to make a
major change now he's just hoping to get
enough for christmas it's going to take
a long time for 70 ships to get unloaded
when the docks are already full of
containers
all those kids bikes that you're waiting
for where are they they're either on
those ships or maybe they're still in
asia
but they're not in warehouses
well you can imagine there are a lot of
moving parts here at the port and it's
going to take a lot of coordination to
make this all work the good news is
shippers like fedex and ups along with
retailers like walmart they are now
pledging to extend their hours so they
could take advantage of the new
overnight hours here at the port tony
all right we'll see if it helps carter
thank you very much